a look at downtown Denver where Pride
colors have been lit to remember the
victims of a deadly nightclub shooting
over the weekend five people died and 17
others were injured thanks for joining
us at 11 o'clock I'm Denise Valdez and
I'm Brian Loftus with Las Vegas known
for having a strong
lgbtqia plus community members are
speaking out tonight about how this
tragedy affects us all Madison Kimbrough
live from their Advocacy Center on
Maryland Parkway now at the latest
yeah we spoke to those at popular gay
nightclubs across town that say tonight
is really a night of reflection as each
shooting that occurs fear sets in
knowing that hate against their
Community still lives on
it was hard it took me back to October
1st when people were not aware of
something that was happening and that it
came out of nowhere and it made me think
more about the people that come here
owner Jim lash of Jimmy's at Madison's a
prominent gay nightclub in Las Vegas
says this weekend's tragedy at Club Q in
Colorado Springs only furthered his
notion that security is a must at his
club we will lock those revolving doors
and we have a magnet door so and the
cameras will show who's on the outside
they buzz and before we let them in
other lgbtqia plus nightclubs across
town sharing their condolences and
concerns with 8 news now quote our
hearts and thoughts go out to the
victims the families affected and the
entire community and at the garage
located near Flamingo and Maryland one
of their co-owners sharing this while
the fear and tragedy are most certainly
senseless and heart-wrenching it is only
the most recently covered one and many
in this and other minority communities
look forward to the days when these Mass
violent events are no longer an issue or
concern over at the center which
provides information resources and
testing for the lgbtqia plus Community
Brian Hosier says while security at
their Center has always been a top
priority now is the time to reach out to
those within the community to show your
support we continue to change we've
upgraded our security over the last
couple years on ways that we can better
equip ourselves and equip this Center so
anyone who comes to visit is safe the
best thing you can do is reach out to
those people you know that identify as
lgbtqia plus we can't do what we do
without our allies and our support
tomorrow night the center which you're
looking at right now is hosting a
community vigil for the Club Q victims
and the vigil will start at 5 30 in the
afternoon and it's open to the public
reporting live Madison Kimbrough 8 News
Now